the jurogan experience
so this thing with dave you don't like
because earthquake is wondering when his
is coming out too well he did he did it
and
he doesn't exactly know when it's coming
out
but man it's hard to get like because
you know dave said hey man whenever
you're ready i'm like yeah yeah i'm
ready and then she said just let me know
well he said my i'm letting you know
hey let's go right but i mean you know
next you know every time you turn around
man dudes chasing them with dresses on
all kinds of [ __ ]
tie your shoes son you in a drag race
run dave bruh
that shit's died down though yeah
they're leaving him alone now he's just
we just realizing how many of the people
that are upset at him didn't even watch
the special yeah they watched the
special and you still are angry at him
and you missed the point the same we was
uh what if it was somewhere man it's me
i was on on the road with louis ck
so i go outside to comedy club some
people out there having a silent protest
and i'm like yo what's up what's going
on and the girl says there's a comedian
in there and he's performing and um
he's really uh he's racist he's name all
of the [ __ ] that they said he is he's
sexist
homophobic
what
and she had said all this [ __ ] i'm
saying he racist too
[Laughter]
i said well [ __ ] that give me a sign
right and she and she was like she was
like no no no we're having a silent
protest i'm like nah [ __ ] that i said
that's his picture right
there i'm gonna [ __ ] him up now i don't
have to stand in line i cut right
through the line and going back i forgot
to cl was it it's somewhere man but it's
like they got a back room with karaoke
like you walk through the back i go on
the back i forgot about that i was
[ __ ] with that girl i think that that
was gonna happen
some back there and then boom
she comes in with the police and [ __ ]
and she's like
you know she wanted to go that's him but
she could she was
right to you no to the policeman to the
policeman okay because we're all sitting
in the back right you know just talking
about whatever it's me uh lynn copplets
and we all just sitting there and the
girl you know cause the girl and the
policeman and the and the manager the
owner of the club come in
because they thought that you were going
back there to [ __ ] up the comedian [ __ ]
up louie yeah right cause because she
saw me i dipped all of you back so she
called the police she didn't call me the
police was right there she got the
police she says i think that guy's going
back to do something today
louis ck yes
so when she come in and she see me first
she's like
like that's the [ __ ] right there
that's the [ __ ] right there
and what happened and i'm like yo what's
up
i'm like yeah i got that
that guy was just joking around right
and and then yeah and then she ended up
she didn't know
what louie had done she
took pictures they gave her a t-shirt
for the club she took a picture with
louie in the green room
she took a picture yes she was just
there because her uh some girl from her
college say yeah let's go do this this
it's protest protest you say ah
that's the thing man it's like so many
of the people that like they haven't
even thought it through they don't even
know what he did
yeah i didn't know what he did if you
were in the room with lo louis when he
jerked off and he said
can i jerk off in front of you and you
said yes
i guess you got an argument that
maybe
you shouldn't have been asked that
question yeah because it puts you in an
uncomfortable situation remember that
joke that kevin brennan used to have
about
consent no i don't know he's like he
says
on the college campus you meet a girl
girl can i kiss you yes you can kiss me
you know can i can we make out can we do
this she says so it gets hot and heavy
so they're they're having sex he says
boom can i do it doggy says yeah yeah
and then he's
he says can i stick it in your head she
said can i stick it in your butt she
goes what he goes do they sell chicken
fingers and pizza hut
it was a little kevin it was a funny
joke you know how he is right he goes uh
and like because everything she's
everything she's down for everything and
ain't gonna
you know can i can i stick it in your
butt
what
because
did you know do they sell chicken
fingers at pizza
so it was like that consent [ __ ] it's
funny when kevin do it it's a timing
thing yeah my bad
but that uh when you were opening for
louis so that was after the controversy
that was after the controversy it was
like we started doing shows again we
went to portugal together oh yeah
portugal we went to portugal and then we
went to uh what is it like doing comedy
in portugal it was dope guess what whip
that that the [ __ ] is he the mayor or
the governor of uh on queen of the south
queen of the south what is that it's a
netflix uh
thing oh i don't know that okay uh but
it's queen of the show it's it's like
the biggest one and he plays he's the
third lead character oh i've never heard
the show have you heard of queen of the
south no there's so many shows though
here we go this is it right here which
guy did you hang out with ah
okay
i never even heard of this [ __ ] show
you know okay from 2016 how is he not on
the first row
maybe he lied
no he is he's like
that's him right there which one right
there go back the second one that guy
that guy right there yeah he lives in
portugal
how do you say his name
i don't know joaquim de
yeah that guy so he lives in portugal it
is in portugal how the [ __ ] is there a
show that has been going on since 2016
and i'm just hearing about now man this
is like one of the hottest shows that's
the thing there's so many what about
this guy this is my man right here let
me scroll back down i want you to see
this guy
which guy i hate this [ __ ] but
he's so good at you hating him you hate
him
oh yeah did you see him did you see um
apocalypto yes i did yeah oh yeah right
and everything oh yeah he was amazing he
was and he said oh he's amazing where is
he an apocalypto is he up there how do
you say his name is gerardo
see right there that's him tara cena
tarasena that guy was a bad [ __ ]
right there okay him an apocalypto oh
yeah and i like the part where he go he
jumped off the waterfalls he said hey my
grandfather hunted in this forest my
father hunted his father and my son and
my son's sons were hunting this forest
[ __ ] you and they said no [ __ ] you and
they jumped off the waterfall too they
said you know
i do remember that okay that was good
that movie was amazing that was man it
was a wild ass [ __ ] movie that was a
dope movie
apocalypse that guy he was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but yeah
yeah he's in queen of south too he was
the main he was the
that you mean he's an [ __ ] on the
show no yeah on that show too on queen
and sound too he he's that guy's
henchman oh okay the guy who i hung out
with in
portugal he's that guy's henchman what
is queen of the south about
uh cocaine oh
and it's about it's on it's on the
cartel level oh it's it's uh
basically
they're big drug dealers who buy
straight from the cartel
so like how
how pablo uh escobar was the cartel
right they're buying from so they would
buy it from pablo and industry yes yeah
and distribute it yeah
they get their hands dirty oh i'm sure
and um
oh yeah then after that we went to uh
brussels and then we went to paris
i went to paris then what is it like
doing stand up in paris
snobby
[Laughter]
is it
like that but it was good they they it's
yeah they they were good paris is good
um
because uh louie's girlfriend lives
there right his girlfriend's like one of
she's
she's like ellen
of paris i guess yeah i'm assuming yeah
yeah she's nice guys but she's like a
real big comedian over there yeah and
his new special i watched his new
special sorry it's very good his new one
it's funny it's very funny
it's interesting it's getting mixed
reviews but i think it's just because
people want to hate them
the people that are louis ck fans will
love it we'll love it yeah i i was at
the cellar one night that the big seller
the um the underground
he's popped in
and i can see the look on the audience
face he did 20 minutes on the pros of
suicide
and i was like you can't do this around
[ __ ] who weak and drunk man
you know what i'm saying yeah because it
was a lot of people going yeah i see his
point that's just why hey [ __ ]
stop talking man
somebody gonna kill himself ahead louie
and uh so yeah
well he's always been like one of the
most prolific guys like he used to put
out a special every year which i think
is too much i think every couple years i
think you want to give the material time
to cook
if you're doing a new special every year
generally speaking i feel like it could
use a little bit more time